[音楽]
今から私が話すことはだー
私があっ
ここ最近で体験した
本当にあった出来事です
[音楽]
お風呂
ほぼ派彼の名前は日
クレイジーながら玉ちゃんグってのこんな所で僕たちはああっ
彼のこと
縦メントを読んでいます
いつからでしょうか
床でてあったかも覚えていません
でしたが気づいた時には
なぜか
私の家に丁寧にするようになっていました
しばらく彼と移転
分かったことがあります
あの男は
変だ
けどあれは a
私が動画編集をしていたときのことです
ふと後ろをみたときのことでした
ああああああ
うわーっ
ブーブーん
あっはぁっ
他の好愛と3人で夜ご飯がどこにために行こうかという話をしていたときのことです
牛丼
フードアリアなぁ
それでは
図面
だってねぇ返事がー
帰って来ませんでしただってねぇ
たてねーああ
外を見てましたあっあっ
うはは
あー全然き空だ
はーはっはっは
ee あああっっっ
[音楽]
私が
一人できれい音スネアた時しなぁ
突然彼から line が届きました
[音楽]
彼は
5時間経ってもくることはありませんでした
悪阻
私は心配になり彼に電話をしてみました
[音楽]
母性
何やってんの
うっくんって言ってなかった
忘れてだろうっ
分かった
ありえ9
ん
[音楽]
これくらい受けました
あ
ああああああん
ran あっはっは
ん
[音楽]
あれは
ん
皆でお菓子を食べながら
喋っていた時の出来事です
すごいよって言われるは彼は誰も
4弓ならない
私がん
は滝
食べやがったなぁんうきつこだけでもう俺これ誰にもあげないタイプだともうあげない
か
味が全然ダメダメなんですよねこれでいいですか
ああ
あっはっは
母ん
という傾かなかっ
あっはっはー
バッハ
あっそして位
もっとも恐ろしい敵事が
この後起きたのです
それ
それねー
イベントやデーという
asan
voodoo
と思うし
私の170万円の財布のくるくるするところ
いい円に
回し覆ったのですなやってるのはこれでもれますは170万と再不斬
えっ細田や俺だったよあっはっはー
熱間ピット空港ですよどうぞくるく邪推
すっなんねー
よね油断ちゃんこれはぁ
ブーブーエルダーだよわぁるどうっううっうぅううあーっはっはっは
ああああああ
ああああハ
[音楽]
ええええええ